このビデオウォッチを最後まで後援して、
彼らの素晴らしいプロダクションカップについてもっと学ぶためのほろ酔い酒に感謝します
[音楽]
私は誰もが大丈夫だと知っていると言う必要はありません
ので、皆さんがそのコメディを楽しんだことを願っています
ビデオさて
、今日のビデオのスポンサーについてお話ししたいと思い
ます。これもほろ酔い酒です。
多くの人
が知っているかもしれませんが、私は実際にはそれほど
酒好きではありませんが
、ほろ酔い酒が届いたときは本当に幸せでした。 私
にとって、私
は彼らの製品が本当に本当に好きなので
、ほとんどのアメリカ人
は適切な日本酒
を飲んだことがないと思います。あなたがアルコールに興味があるかどうかに関係なく、
歴史と文化の背後にある高品質の製品
は試してみる価値があると思います。
彼らが
本物の日本文化
を西に紹介しているという考えが本当に好きです、
そして例えば箱の中に含まれているのは
初心者のためのこのほろ酔いソケットガイドであり、
彼らは彼らが話しているさまざまな味の
プロファイルについて話します 深さどのように
酒
が作られるかさまざまな種類の型
が入りますたとえば
、グレードの点でさまざまな種類の酒
がどの種類の酒を生産するか
、そして彼らは
ここにこの本当に素晴らしいチャートを持ってい
ます 少し見づらいです
が、それぞれのソケットに
どんな食べ物が合うかを話し
、それに加えて
、箱の中に日本酒ごとにユニークなカードがある
ので、これがツールです たとえば
、雪の乙女と彼らは
醸造所について、会社の歴史に瓶詰めされている
と話します。
これらの会社自体の
歴史は、米国の歴史全体とほぼ同じくらい古いので、これはそうではありません。
アメリカのパレットのために作られたのは、
それが面白いと思うこと
です。あなたが期待する
ように、彼らが送ったボトルの
それぞれは、他のボトルとはまったく異なる独自の味のプロファイルを持ってい
ます。
それらがすべて
ソケットであり、実際に
味覚テストを行うことを考えているという事実
は、
ライブのYouTubeビデオまたは
単収縮ビデオでこれらの6つの異なるソケットタイプのそれぞれを連続して試すことです
が、まだ決定していませんが、 結局
、説明ボックスにリンクを下に置く
ので
、ほろ酔い酒のおかげで下のチェックダウンを見ることに興味があるなら、すぐに
またみんなと話します